sofia votre maman elle vous appelle vous
annonce moi je suis à ce moment là je
suis je suis déjà un peu stressé parce
qu'on m'informe contre ans pas mon père
et puisque j'ai l'habitude mois enfin je
trouvais ça directement bizarre parce
que mon père je suis habitué ce qu'ils
m'appellent tout le temps quand il est
sur la route quand l'un disant en chemin
pour travailler il ivresse et c'est plié
ses colis pour passer le et bien sûr oui
toi ils nous passent nous appelle ses il
est équipé d'un kit mon grand père la
famille il a apprécié plusieurs fois
puisque certaines informations fausses
son véhicule et à ce propos à cause de
la police bien sûr parce qu'ils ont ils
ont soutenu que mon père avait le
téléphone à la main alors que il a
toujours sont pas là un kit savez tous
comment nos pions en bois comme tous les
livres
actuellement donc à ce moment là j'étais
pas rassuré parce que depuis mon rêve et
je l'avais pas eu au téléphone
donc je les appelais et c'est bizarre
mon père il me répond tout le temps il
peut être occupé même avec un client il
va me répondre il va me laisser en
attente
cela me faire comprendre qui il est
occupé mais il va prendre le temps
répond donc vous êtes se disent passe
quelque chose donc là j'ai eu montée de
stress et de panique mais il fallait pas
que je la laisse paraître parce que
j'étais aux côtés de mon petit frère
il s'a de trois ans donc vous savez les
enfants de ce groupe arrive à savoir à
capter quand même quelque chose de grave
qui se passe donc une fois qu'ils sont
arrivés à l'hôpital
moi j'ai pu avoir par mon oncle que
juste l'état était grave et qu'il
fallait vite qu'on prenne nos jambes à
mon cou et vous et pêche de venir au
chevet d'une perte tout à ce moment là
en plus vous connaissez paris avec les
bouchons bon et c'est sa politesse
montrent la paille look la panique la
panique en arrivant rien ne me rassure
pas ce que je le voit entouré de
machines ainsi que ba censées ces
machines 6 passes et moi je ne peux pas
vivre
donc moi le premier réflexe est
débranché pas j'ai même pas penser à
comment ça s'est passé qui quoi enfin la
première réduction rassurer mon petit
frère mes frères et soeurs restés auprès
de ma famille est prié ce qui marche
et ce qui m'a empêché de pas tomber par
terre à ce moment là c'est c'est prier
parce que comme ma mère la wla l'a
expliqué au miracle et j'y crois encore
aujourd'hui c'est quoi à quoi je crois
encore le plus c'est c'est c'est tout ça
à bas se termine en paix en justice que
la justice soit faite parce que après
tout ça ces derniers jours où j'ai pas
dormi j'ai pas bu j'ai empêché mon corps
de se nourrir parce que j'avais peur de
pas resté assez longtemps auprès de mon
père c'est qu'on le veuille ou non c'est
au fond que c'est peut-être les derniers
instants je suis resté et au moment où
l'heure fatale bas à l'arrivée on m'a
dit que ça y est quoi qu'il arrive eux
mêmes avec mes prières ça il allait
parvenir
et c'est là que tout s'est enchaîné
pourquoi comment
mon papa qui est moins gros qui est mon
amoureux c'est l'homme de ma vie
si ça parce que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de filles beaucoup de faire vos
coupes personne qui peut vous prend à
peine d'être est aujourd'hui si sur ce
plateau vraiment pour transmettre cette
peine parce que je pense que ça touche
souvent les mauvais les bons n'écoute
non parce que l'individu humain
m'enlever mon père à moi mes frères et
soeurs
certains qui sont derrière je sais que
je ne retrouverai pas donc voilà ce qui
m'aide ce courage c'est dignité qu'on
n'arrête pas nous dire c'est vraiment c
c'est la fois et on croit quand même un
peu encore à la justice
c'est la première fois que vous
témoignez soufia non c'est chez vous
c'est en fait la deuxième on va dire
mais ça prend une fois que je suis un
peu de tout ça ça paraît un peu tôt à
part les coups parlement parler et à
arriver
un livre et surtout quand
je le vois comme ça était vraiment plein
de vie plein de projets pleins de bonnes
intentions s'était il avait un coeur
mais immense c'est c'est un grand gâchis
c'est une grande perte est taxé pour le
consoler ouais voilà on espère pour nous
consoler que ça se reproduira plus bas
d'hier appui que cette perte la cette
douleur là elle dira à guérir un
d'autres personnes et l empêchera que sa
sauce ça sera commence justement doria
aujourd'hui vous êtes venu témoigner
avec sofia aujourd'hui qu'est ce que qui
vous en voulez et qu'est ce que vous
réclamez voilà qu'est ce qu'on voulait
maintenant parce que c'est vrai que
cédric déjà franchement dans l'urgence
pour le principe et pour nous rassurer
qu on peut effectivement croire en cette
justice je comprends pas qu'ils aient
aucune mesure qui a été prise vis-à-vis
de ces trois ou quatre individus qui
sent directement
il ya une enquête en cours actuellement
c'est ça c'est ça il ya une plainte qui
a été déposée sur pour l'instant ils ont
retenu homicide involontaire moi j'ai un
peu de problèmes avec le mot
involontaire après bon voilà je perds
pas la raison pour autant et je monte
pas dans la m je me dis sur le coup
quand tu es là ils l'interpellent isis
pas tiens celui-là on va le tuer vous
les avez rencontré les avait vus
m'écouter moi j'essaie dame qui a oui à
part cette dame
à part ces dames non j'ai rencontré
personne nous de ce que j'ai pu lire
dans la presse
on nous parle d'un individu qui serait
meurtri ils se sont pas manifestés on
n'a pas eu de nouvelles
on s'est beaucoup inquiété trop tard de
l'état de santé de mon mari on s'est
beaucoup inquiété de l'état
psychologique de mon mari moi mon mari
j'ai 8h04 il m'a appelé il m'a dit allô
chérie ça va ça va la route ça se passe
bien on est tranquille et sinon toi ben
ouais ceci cela ou ryan ce soir faut
qu'on lui parle c'est notre et un autre
est né on avait une petite on avait
prévu une petite réunion familiale avant
que le
le week end commence on s'est dit
l'avocat des pauvres on se débarrasse
d'elle parce qu'elle a tendance à
défendre son frère
on essayait de les diviser pour mieux
les dominer parce qu'ils sont non savez
je vous appelle vous avez 5
il se défend d'entre eux donc on a
commencé rapidement à mettre une
stratégie en place au téléphone et je
lui dis mais sinon à part ça il y avait
un truc en particulier au chaos parce
que c'est en discutant on peut oublier
la raison dit non je t'appelais juste
pour dire que j'étais de très très bonne
humeur j'écoute ces deux là vous tant
mieux je suis dit bon écoute tant mieux
ça me fait plaisir quand tu m'appelles
et tu me dis que tu est super bonne
humeur voilà ce qui m'a dit et la veille
la dernière conversation vous avez la
dernière conversation que j'ai eue au
téléphone est l'avant dernière c'était
dans le salon moi j'allais pour me
coucher
on regarde beaucoup la télé à partir de
22h 21h pour vous regarder son mari vous
moi je vous regarde pas mon mari et les
enfants vous regarde puisque moi je suis
aux fourneaux et il était plein plein de
bonnes résolutions il s'était ainsi si
dans un truc de sport vous savez avec
des électro à chatou à levallois zone on
verra donc il est plein de bonnes
résolutions et puis s'est dit bon je me
mets à la soupe est floue que c'est
effectivement il avait pris un peu de
poids
donc il a fait sa soupe aux choux et
avant de dormir je les lis tu me l'as
mix et après je la rends je congèle
memic cela il m'a dit waouh est inquiète
tu t'inquiètes je fais je dis bon je
sais que tu vas pas le faire au pire des
cas à 5h jamie qui est déjà et je la
mets dans jamais dans le congèle mais en
fin de compte il n'a pas mixer gelé pas
mixer non plus ea et puis voilà c'est
normal c'est votre centre ouest où vous
nous expliquer aussi le contexte